- So I'm watching this whole Matt Gaetz,
Gaetzgate scandal
unfold in real time with the same amount
of astonishment and amusement
as all of you.
And the facts are coming
out incredibly rapidly.
Is this a trafficking investigation?
Is this an extortion investigation?
We'll find out probably soon.
But I will say this.
There is one thing that
we can all agree on,
and that is that Matt Gaetz
needs to shut up.
He's not doing himself any
favors going on Tucker,
going on a tweet storm on Twitter.
This is not how you put up a
potential criminal defense.
It's not even how you deal with
a potential extortion ring
where your father may
have been wearing a wire.
- They asked my dad to
wear a wire, which he did.
- Matt Gaetz, do yourself a favor
and stop talking.
You've already done enough damage.
- Smearing me and ruining
the investigation.
- Otherwise, I might see you
in court.